there's a standoff between Italian
officials and a rescue ship carrying
hundreds of migrants and refugees
[Music]
people on a vessel operated by Doctors
Without Borders are waiting for
permission to disembark in Catania the
boat carrying 572 passengers docked
earlier on Monday but authorities only
allowed minors families and people with
health issues to leave the ship
another rescue ship arrived in Italy on
Saturday Humanity one that's its name
was allowed to dock in Catania as well
but now has been ordered to leave the
Sicilian Port its Captain however
refuses to go until everyone on board is
allowed to leave and he is threatening
to go to court over this so far 144
people including Miners and people with
health conditions have been let off the
ship dozens of single men were refused
at that permission
let's bring in Tony bertley now he joins
us from the port of Catania so Tony
where are we with this the ships are
still refusing to leave I assume
absolutely no one's budging an inch on
this matter at the moment there's a
there's pride and pressure at stake and
I think the pride is from the Italian
government this was very much a uh a
political decision that was basically
born out of the uh prime minister
um uh Miss Malone Mrs Maloney about
wanting to have a hard Crackdown on
migration and this is probably the end
result of that they're making a stand on
this it seems unfair to many people
especially the humanitarian
organizations who are helping these
people and they're talking about the
terrible harrowing trauma they've been
going through in order to get to this
point and then the terrible
disappointment and not being able to
disembark and start a new life and and
be processed here it's very difficult I
mean the desperation is shown not so
long ago three people from the geober
rents uh three migrant threw themselves
into the water tried to escape that way
they were caught and brought back by the
um Italian police but it shows the
amount of desperation and that's only
building and I think the tension also
but at the moment as you said before the
captain of the ship they're saying
they're not budging the government has
not said anything about what they're
going to do now but this is probably
playing to the supporters who voted for
uh Mrs Maloney because this is exactly
what they wanted they see this as an
invasion they see this as basically the
humanitarian organizations actually
being the enemy so this is playing so
the difficulty is now how do we move on
what's going to go budge first who's
going to Blink it's very difficult to
say at the moment
all right Tony thank you very much there
are another two rescue ships in the area
the German run rise above is here it's
overcrowded with 93 people on a boat
that's only 25 meters long and the ocean
Viking is anchored just nearby that one
is operated by the European charity SOS
mediterhane and it is carrying 234
migrants neither ship has received a
response to repeated requests to Doc